I don't have much of a voice right now
cause I'm kind of losing my voice,
but I wanted to give you all a Sunday recap.
So this morning started out normal.
We did chores,
the boys milked the cows.
We came inside the house and got ready for church.
We were on our way to church and realize that Dottie R.
Heifer was going into labor.
She actually delivered a beautiful female calf,
but unfortunately, it was a stillborn,
which was so disappointing.
After church, though,
we started milking her.
I got most of the colostrum out.
She did really well for never being milked before.
This is a heifer,
so she's never had a calf before.
This is her first time being milked.
Then we went down to my mom's house in the yard. Looked so beautiful.
We had dinner outside,
and then I went inside the shop because we have a little
spot in the shop now that we're selling some ballerina farm goods.
We brought down sourdough kids and candles
and all our wooden utensils and honey and seasoning and dish soap,
granola, all of it.
And then this week,
we're also gonna be adding some meat and croissants down there
as well, which is just so exciting.
So if you're local,
come by the flower shop because there's lots of goodies.
And then we just stayed and hang.
Hung out with cousins and spend time with family.
And then we raced home and milk daddy Again for her evening, Milky